College is expensive.
Like, really expensive.
Especially here… in the Unites States of
guns, fast food, and student debt.
It wasn’t always this way.
In 1980, the average cost of tuition for one
year at a four year private college was $3,500.
Adjusted for inflation, that’s $10,200 2016
dollars.
Today, that same year of college goes for
$32,000—3 times as much as only 36 years
ago.
So what’s behind this?
Well that’s both a complicated and controversial
question.
To understand why college has risen in cost
we first have to understand why college has
always been expensive.
The biggest fraction of your tuition goes
to salaries.
The national average student to faculty ratio
is 18 to 1 meaning that for every 18 students
there is 1 faculty member.
The average professor at a private college
makes $126,981 per year.
Divided by 18 that comes out to only $7,054
which doesn’t seem that bad but you have
to consider that there’s more than just
faculty.
There’s also coaches, and gardeners and
kitchen staff and dorm staff and maintenance
people and admissions staff and marketers
and IT staff and security guards and college
presidents.
All together, the salaries and benefits of
all these individuals add up to a whopping
$24,000 of our $32,000 tuition.
Salaries tend to be high because college functions
similarly to many other industries—following
the rules of supply and demand.
The most popular college majors vary over
time because interests change to reflect changes
in culture.
The problem is, you can’t just magically
create new professors.
By the time new professors go through their
20 years of education and specialize in a
field, that major will no longer be the popular
one so when a major is popular, colleges have
to compete to get professors and the only
thing that really matters is money—money
brings more professors, more professors brings
more students, and more students brings more
money.
At the same time, professors in historically
popular majors receive tenure.
Tenure is the idea that in order to promote
academic freedom, long-time professors should
have their job guaranteed until retirement.
With professors that legally cannot be let
go, there can often be an abundance of professors
in less popular study areas.
So, we still have $8,000 of tuition unaccounted
for.
Colleges need places to teach and their infrastructure
is rather unnaturally expensive.
Classes usually only run for eight or ten
hours a day, five days a week, for 40 or so
weeks a year.
That means that classrooms are only in use
23% of the time.
The college still has to pay for the space
the other 77% of the time which of course
adds up.
Additionally, colleges really like to build
nice buildings because these attract students.
The average cost to build a building varies
by location, but it averages between $115
and $215 per square foot.
By contrast, U-Mass Amherst’s Commonwealth
Honors College cost $354 per square foot,
U-Mass Boston’s General Academic Building
No. 1 cost $594 per square foot, and Berkely’s
Lower Sproul Building cost $659 per square
foot.
Of course there are other factors contributing
to the high price of college, but staffing
and buildings are the big two.
Now for the reason college has tripled in
price.
It’s always been expensive to pay highly
educated people to teach in inefficiently
used buildings so what has changed in the
last thirty years?
Well, college is more popular than ever.
In the last 20 years, college enrollment has
increased by 50%.
Federal and state funding for colleges has
actually increased to an all time high since
1980 but with the simultaneous increase in
students, per-student funding has hit an all
time low.
In 1990, Ohio’s flagship public university—Ohio
State University—paid for 25% of their budget
with government money while in 2012, only
7% of their budget was paid for by the state.
With less federal and state money, students
have to pay more out of pocket to make up
the difference.
Additionally, colleges have changed to appeal
to the millennial generation.
According to William Strauss and Neil Howe,
the millennial generation—born between 1982
and 2004—are characterized by seven core
traits: they are sheltered, confident, team-oriented,
conventional, pressured, achieving, and they
feel special.
Sometimes called “trophy kids,” millennials
tend to be more ambitious and feel more unique
than the preceding generation which means
that they tend to believe more in “the right
fit” idea for college.
Colleges responded to this new attitude by
adding more and more amenities to help them
stand out to the growing number of students.
All these new amenities required more and
more management which contributed to the boom
in administration at universities.
According to the US Department of Education,
the number of administrator positions increased
60% between 1993 and 2009 which is 10 times
faster than the number of tenured professor
positions.
So just as I finished my “Why Flying is
so Expensive” video by telling you that
flying is not that expensive, I’ll finish
this video by telling you that college is
not that expensive.
85 percent of full-time degree seeking students
at four year universities receive some sort
of financial aid with the average grant hovering
around $15,500.
That’s a significant amount, but I’ll
admit there’s still a significant amount
left over, until you consider that going to
college is the single greatest investment
you can make in your life, especially today.
People who go to college earn on average 98%
more per hour than those who only have a high
school diploma and that number is up from
only 40% more 35 years ago.
So given that, what’s the true cost of college?
When you look at it holistically, over your
whole life, the cost of going to college is
not $32,000 a year or $128,000 over four years,
but rather negative $500,000.
By skipping the opportunity to go to college,
you will forfeit on average half a million
dollars in potential earnings.
Go to college kids.
Thank you for watching!
I’m very excited to say for the first time
ever… this video is sponsored by audible.com.
Audible is a company that I admire a lot and
have used for years before this sponsorship.
As I imagine any subscriber of Wendover Productions
does too, I love learning and a great way
to learn is through reading books.
The problem is, I live a busy life and rarely
have time to sit down and read a book.
Instead I fit reading into my schedule by
listening to books when driving, doing dishes,
running, whenever.
Audible has an amazing selection of 250,000
titles including one of the best non-fiction
books of all time and a personal favorite
of mine, Freakonomics which can be yours,
for free, forever, by signing up for a 30
day free trial using the link www.audible.com/wendover.
Alternatively, you can download any other
book for free with that free trial.
Using that link to sign up for a free trial
is the single biggest way you can help support
Wendover Productions so I do hope you consider
it.
Aside from that, you can subscribe to this
channel if you haven’t already by clicking
the button here, or follow me on twitter @WendoverPro.
You can also check out last week’s video
on Dagen H—the day Sweden switched driving
directions—here.
Thank you again and I’ll see you soon for
another Wendover Productions video.